we have a voicemail number that number
is
2192 David P here is a voicemail about
the new Finance Channel yes we have a
finance Channel youtube.com
pacmanfinance you know we get so many
voicemails from people who just don't
understand what the hell I'm talking
about and I usually blame myself I must
be a terrible Communicator this caller
knows exactly what the Pacman Finance
channel is and is supposed to be take a
listen
hey David I'd like to thank you so much
for you know uh creating the Pacman
Finance YouTube channel thank you I
really like the content that you've been
producing it's very simple
um nothing too Exquisite like talking
about oh which stock should I buy or
when should I buy Tesla just really
simple you know personal finance that I
really feel like a lot of people are
missing out today especially in regards
to uh credits to uh credit scores
learning how to budget uh stuff like
that and I mean
and also the fact that you know you're
not like Dave Ramsey that's also a very
refreshing thing yes yeah again thank
you so much for creating the Pacman
Finance Channel and I look forward to
seeing you know seeing the channel you
know get up to you know one million well
listen I don't know about a million
subscribers but I have to tell you
the Pacman Finance channel has grown
more quickly out of the gate to 10 000
subscribers than any other channel or
project we've been involved in now I
want to remind everybody I have nothing
to sell you it is an alternative to
these right wing Finance folks Dave
Ramsey who gives Financial advice but
he's anti-vaxx and has horrible
Employment Practices he's been accused
of at his organization you don't need
that you can get all the information
without the anti-vaxx nuttery okay so
indeed there's no stock picking there's
none of that check out the channel
youtube.com
pacmanfinance more than 11 000
subscribers it's all free there's
nothing you even could pay for if you
wanted it's all free so many basic
personal finance topics I always say we
should start teaching this stuff to 12
year olds
and we don't so we're offering it for
free on the channel okay
recent topics the hidden cost of low
prices okay how low prices can actually
lead to more spending is it better to
pay with cash or credit cards
understanding the math of retirement
why health insurance is important Roth
versus traditional IRAs understanding
net worth why the stock market has been
down improving your credit score why you
shouldn't bother trying to time the
market all of these things it is just
free
simple topics okay youtube.com
pacmanfinance if more folks knew the
stuff and understood the content that
was on this channel we would have way
fewer people fall for financial scams
number one and in general people would
be better off in terms of understanding
their financial position no stock picks
If You're Expecting stock picks this is
not the channel for you if you're
expecting anti-vaxx this is not the
channel for you go to Dave Ramsey for
the anti-vax finance stuff youtube.com
Pacman Finance okay enough
on today's bonus show great bonus show
today
yet another acquittal
related to Durham Trump and Republicans
have been saying oh Durham's going to
get this person that person it's going
to be crazy yet another Durham acquittal
it's a humiliation for the right Wingers
the White House is pushing ahead on a
plan to research the idea of cooling the
Earth by reflecting sunlight back out
into space
discussed in science fiction for decades
could it become a reality we will talk
about it today on the bonus show and
also I know that I just told you that
the new British prime minister uh
replacing Boris Johnson is Liz trust
she's been in what a few weeks she's
already only Hanging On by a thread
party members are calling for her to be
removed and this could be one of the
shortest tenures as British prime
minister in British history fascinating
I guess not good for Liz truss but maybe
good for the people of the UK all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad thank
your lucky stars every day you're not
Dave Pacman well many of our viewers do
thank their lucky stars every single day
that they have access to the bonus show
sign up at joinpakman.com we will see
you on the bonus show or otherwise back
here tomorrow